welcome to philanthropy in action where  we engage  anthropos activist students and the  community in discussions and how we use  our time talent and treasure to make the  world a better place I am Maxum thorne  and I teach philanthropy in action at  Yale today's guest is Beth Neville Evans  it is cendant from a long line of  missionaries and the president of extend  Foundation which is doing important work  in Guatemala Beth Neville thank you so  much for coming it is such a pleasure to  see you again and for making the trip to  new haven fun over here thank you we  also have with us students from Yale  University well who asked to introduce  themselves starting with cecen and I am  from Los Angeles and JT college Carl hi  I'm Carl I'm also from NASA Los Angeles  and I'm a junior my name is Matias  Pilates and I'm from Newark Delaware say  California my name is some of the guy in  the corner  my name is Owen thanks and I'm a  sophomore from Richland Washington